the witch wound affects men in a totally
different way because they were actually
supposed to protect those women who were
burned so like people really negate men
from the witch wound but like that is
outrageous because imagine if it was
your sister or your daughter or your
wife who's being stripped out of your
house and put up on a pyre or drowned
there is a massive witch wound and of
course like you know men also like
anyone who was practicing magic or
earth-based wisdom or using the medicine
of plants which was the only medicine we
had with the Cults of Isis I love just
the magic of utilizing energy as
technology that's what Tantra really is
is like energetic Alchemy this Elemental
Union of like breath and sound and
movement through the body and the Sweet
Waters and the sweat and the tears and
like all of the elements that make up
our bodies wielding them for our desires
for our healing